i've been saying for now well over a
year
he is not fit to serve he is not fit to
serve
he's one of the most incompetent
presidents in the history of the united
states of america
and so the idea that i think he
shouldn't be out of office yesterday
is not the issue the question is
what happens with 14 days left to go or
13 days left to go
and i think that what
81 million people stood up and said it's
time for him to go
and the united states senate voted
93-6 to confirm
that we should be sworn in we were
we were duly elected so i think it's
important we get on with the business
of getting him out of office the
quickest way that that will happen
is us being sworn in on the 20th what
action happens before or after that
is a judgment for the congress to make
but that's what i am looking forward to
him leaving office i was told that on
the way up here
way over here that he indicated he
wasn't going to show up
at the uh at the inauguration one of the
few things he and i have ever agreed on
it's a good thing i'm not showing up
earlier you'd said that
if you'd hope that he would show up only
in the sense that it was valuable to
send a signal to the world about the
transfer of power
you've clearly changed your perspective
on that because he has
clearly demonstrated he's exceeded even
my worst notions about him
he's been an embarrassment to the
country embarrassed us around the world
not worthy not worthy to hold that
office
if we were six months out we should be
moving
everything to get him out of office and
teaching him again
invoke trying to invoke the 25th
amendment whatever it took
to get him out of office but i am
focused now
on us taking control as president and
vice president
on the 20th and to get our agenda moving
as quickly as we can